[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the song
pippacrira and harry cole they were with
us from now until just before midnight
as ever though to the front pages first
of all and the guardian leading with the
liverpool explosion story they write
about the terror threat level being
raised to severe
the telegraph also going with that they
have an image of ahmad al-swelmin the
man who police believe made and
detonated a bomb
the metro quotes the taxi driver david
perry's wife who described him as lucky
to be alive after his cab was blown up
yesterday outside a hospital in
liverpool while he was sitting inside it
the eye splashes with the prime
minister's plea for people over the age
of 40 to get covered booster jabs for
which they will become eligible
the manchester evening news and a number
of its sister titles carry the same
front page reacting to the decision to
abandon the leg of the hs2 high-speed
rail line that would have run between
the midlands and leeds
the yorkshire post says the decision
puts the government's leveling up agenda
in doubt
the financial times leads with royal
dutch shell's decision to change where
it is domiciled for tax purposes from
the netherlands to the uk
so let's get the thoughts then of pippa
and harry and uh starting with the
incident uh now described as a terror
attack pippa in liverpool um and the uh
the suspect in that named this evening
with an appeal for police really to for
people to come forward with any
information about him
yes i mean this is not as
straightforward a case as sometimes um
these incidents
are in that it's emerged that the
suspect uh emmerdale swimming who was
originally from the middle east um and i
think came to the uk by syria had in
fact converted to christianity and that
the police also also feel that he
may have had mental health issues um so
it's been obviously branded a terrorist
incident by the police but that's as
much to do with the methodology of the
attack as it is uh the motivation
obviously it looks like it was some sort
of suicide device
although there are also questions over
whether it possibly detonated sooner and
whether the hospital was in fact the
intended final destination for the bomb
as you know it was remembered on sunday
and the hospital is not far from the
main liverpool cathedral memorial
service remembrance sunday service that
was going on so the question marks there
too and it is of course it's possible
that the device designated earlier the
guardian
raises some of those questions
clearly the police have a lot more work
to do
um they're been out on the streets of
liverpool since the incident uh several
arrests have been made but there are big
question marks remaining as to what the
ultimate motivation was uh even though
they've identified uh the the suspect
and the anders i mean the guardian
points out there the uh the terror
threat level raised harry um this is
after also the death of david amos and
in a sense we were reminded today it's
to increase the vigilance of all of us
yeah that's right they're not saying
those two events are linked but the fact
that both happened in a month meant that
the joint intelligence committee that
looks at the terror threat uh with the
advice of cobra after a discussion on
advice of uh security officials uh have
said that you know it does mean that
another attack is highly likely and
there are real fears tonight um speaking
to social security world that this
could be uh quite a tricky winter um the
security services we've been reporting
for for weeks now are are pretty much at
breaking point they are hit by a sort of
perfect storm of tight budgets and uh
the end of lockdown increasingly
radicalized people lone wolves who
many of them aren't on the on the on the
radar so to speak already and um the the
the the sort of the sort of word they
use for these sort of attacks are a nike
attacks because they just do it and
there's not many things you can do to
stop it you know we saw with david amis
a very simple but
brutally effective attack and whereas
this one was a little bit more
complicated uh and thankfully touchwood
it appears that it did not go off uh as
intended
that said i think the really interesting
thing that's um really struck me in the
last 48 hours uh since the 24 40 hours
36 sorry hours since the attack
um
is if you look back at how uh great
manchester police who are overseeing
this now as a part of northwest terror
um response unit
obviously were heavily criticized in the
wake of the manchester arena bombings
where there was almost a void of
information and
intelligence shared with um five eyes
allies like the united states was
starting to appear in the new york times
before it was appearing in british media
and i think it's been a real concerted
effort actually to release information
accurate information
as it as and when it happens we we
almost know more about the suspect and i
have to say it would have been a grizzly
process of identification it took a long
time to to get to a stage where even now
they're saying we we we strongly believe
it is this person it's still not
possible to formally identify that what
what is left of that body but they are
being very open um with the information
they have and trying to
shut down that sort of
void of misinformation that can erupt
very quickly with social media um
as it did in the wake of the manchester
bombing so i think that in itself is
worth noting as a as a you know a grim a
grim time but a marked improvement by
a police force that has had it in the
air rightly for for many many months uh
hopefully beginning to get a better grip
on these sort of things yes a lessons
learned moment no doubt but much of that
evidence no doubt is coming from the
taxi driver who was in the vehicle and
as we see from the metro is indeed lucky
to be alive as a as we found out from
the statement from his wife pictured
there rachel and david uh seen um and he
seen it right at the bottom there
escaping those flames quite an
extraordinary for him to get out of that
yeah well that footage was incredible
wasn't it where um somebody caught on
cctv or in a camera phone the car
pulling into the car park of the
hospital
and the you see this grey smoke emerging
from it and the
um
as the device goes off and then this
figure emerging from the car and and
running away and it later obviously
transpired it was it was the taxi driver
david perry and here's his wife
saying frankly
what that uh that footage uh showed us
all was that he was lucky to be alive
and you know we sort of throw the term a
hero around an awful lot but to have had
the presence of mine to lock it looks
like he locked the the suspect in the
car and you know as we said possibly
wasn't the final destination and then
possibly prevented a much uh you know
much more serious incident um you know
he uh
we we threw that term here around and in
this case it's very highly deserved and
i know that lots of people are
suggesting
that he
should be awarded with some sort of
civilian honor but you know i'd i'd be
amongst them i'd be happy to see that i
think that uh it's the sort of presence
of mind the sort of instinctive
um bravery that he showed there um could
have potentially
averted a much much bigger disaster and
it's going to be fascinating in the
coming days to hear more from him as to
how he felt and how he acted the way he
did why he acted the way he did
and we as we learn more about the
incident
absolutely we'll wait and see how that
uh that investigation continues shall we
and see what more information they
release but um moving on to another
story um headache for the government uh
potentially towards the end of this week
uh which is rail and already the
northern newspapers um
not happy about this uh as we can see
from uh many of them harry
yes so we saw the the long-awaited sort
of leveling up integrated rail review
that will look at
how journey times can and capacity can
be increased across areas of the rail
infrastructure the creaking rail
infrastructure many would say that has
not had the you know the same attention
and investment that uh the south east
and london have had now
it strikes me as this
announcement's gone up a little bit
cack-handedly because elements of it
were dripped out over the weekend uh
crucially the the key fact that the
uh sort of open secret in whitehall
really and we've all been sort of
writing you know expected to uh the the
leg that goes of the of hs2 the railway
that will one day build be
built but not not anytime soon won't be
now going to leeds and instead uh
investment in rail will be going
into different different parts of the
rail railway around leeds will get its
own tram system apparently uh but there
crucially won't be that ability to get
the same high-speed train all the way
from london to leeds so big
disappointment tonight the whole review
is coming on thursday
um i would argue that it would probably
have been a wiser move perhaps if you
were gonna trail some of this stuff to
do it in papers like the yorkshire post
or the manchester evening news or or the
papers in leeds because you know it
seems to me that the the regional press
has seen drips and drabs and topspin in
sunday papers and are rightly very angry
about it um obviously the manchester
even news leading the way with the reach
group who um
uh associated the mirror the yorkshire
post there obviously another great big
uh northern paper however not getting
involved in that it's a different a
different company that publishes that
but it's clear you know regardless of
the the slightly dated graphic but it's
clear the message on you know across all
the papers is is the same that actually
come on boris johnson was swept to sweat
to power given his majority on grand
promises of infrastructure spending and
leveling up and
investment in the north and um you know
need to start sort of putting that money
where where the mouth is there will be
96 billion pounds
invested across uh across the region but
it does so far doesn't seem to be
landing or being sold particularly well
and i guess on these train projects uh
pippa it's this it's the double whammy
of hs2 which was from london to
birmingham then often hawaii
wasn't it you know one to one to
manchester um and the northwest and then
either one to leeds and then you've also
got the the northern powerhouse rail
line which is the east-west line across
the penins between manchester and leeds
and all those towns in between who were
desperate for that connectivity and the
double whammy of both of these seemingly
being pulled is is what's get getting in
there in their throat certainly what
what is this is this the chancellor
saying no what's happened
yes well discussions have been going on
for some time between the treasury and
number 10 about the the rail
infrastructure element of boris
johnson's leveling up plans and as we
know the chancellor of any chancellor's
job is to try and rein in the spending
of a prime minister and particularly in
this case where we have a prime minister
whose national inclination seems to be
spend more than some conservatives are
comfortable with and the chancellor who
despite the extra money he uh was lucky
enough to end up with um at the budget
uh is still nevertheless very conscious
of the huge amount we spent on the
response to the coronavirus crisis and
the fact that you know going forward
there's some very difficult choices
ahead this is one of those difficult
choices and it looks like um that for
the time being the treasury has has won
this particular battle obviously we'll
have to wait till thursday to see all
the detail but um for all those people
across swathes of the north yorkshire um
and bits of bits of homicide who were
promised
what their definition of leveling up
transfer infrastructure was one of the
key aspects of that and you know to be
to be promised a high-speed railway rail
line a new one and to find that actually
only a very small portion of that is
going to be built and you're going to
end up with upgrades to existing lines
instead
particularly when regardless these sorts
of upgrades take a very long time to
come to fruition so even if the
government's saying well actually it's
going to save us money and we'll event
you know we'll be able to deliver
speedier trains and capacity just do it
more cheaply people will need to see it
to believe it and there's already a lot
of sort of you know fears on the story
about benches that uh
for all the talk of sleeves bringing
boris johnson down or at least damaging
him actually the thing which penetrates
most with photos is delivery and if his
flagship project of leveling up the
country one of the key aspects of that
isn't able to deliver any sort of
tangible benefits people's change to
people's lives by the next election then
you know he's potentially on on more
shaky grounds so you know this has
potentially huge electoral con electoral
consequences we'll have to see the
detail on thursday but it will
inevitably be painted by the opposition
as promises made and promises broken and
that's dangerous territory for boris
johnson well brush johnson's certainly
sounding very positive about it in the
news conference today that he gave but
uh perhaps that is expectation
management one wonders um
to be fair to the government uh the
suggestion is they think similar
reductions in journey times can be
achieved by upgrading existing lines and
adding new sections but as you say we
await the details don't we on on
thursday on that one
lots more still to come will covet
booster jabs for the over 40s allow us
all to have something like a normal
christmas we will discuss that after
this
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now peppa cruz and harry
cole welcome back to both of you and so
harry to the eye then uh get the booster
jabs to save christmas all hail the
vaccine once again as uh pretty much the
well the only route out of this in
england at least um
[Music]
tell me more absolutely absolutely
treated not to one but two uh prime
minister press conferences uh in 24
hours um boris johnson was back with the
classic lineup today boris and the
boffins chris whittie and professor
valance as they sort of bang the drum
yes once again so
40 year olds can now will now shortly be
able to apply for their booster jabs and
you can see it won't be long before 30
year olds and 20 year olds and everyone
will have a boost jab there's a really
interesting point in the press
conference today as well where the pm
kind of let it slip i didn't think it
wanted to be his main message of the of
the of the of the day
but he basically implied that eventually
three jabs
will be the the the definition of fully
vaccinated um so as you know the vaccine
passports to go to travel for
hassle-free travel i suppose and for
entry into large events as we currently
have it will be um on the nhs vaccine
pass it will be three jabs required now
it doesn't take a cynic to um
to wonder how long that would be for
jabs and nadim zahawi very recently when
he interviewed a cop
again former maxine minister said
eventually it will just be an annual an
annual booster so
um you know we have been hearing about
this you know the jab all year and i
suspect we'll be hearing about it for a
lot longer um but frankly if it works if
it is the way of keeping the economy
open
um the you know all the
anti-anti-vaxxers of the world can
scream until they're you know blue in
the face but um if it works people are
going to take it yeah and we see nations
like austria for example uh with rules
for the unvaccinated uh that are
different for the vaccinated in terms of
lockdown um but just very quickly on
this paper in terms of the language the
prime minister is using storm cloud's
brewing the waves are rolling in and
many many epidemiologists are suggesting
that we've been in this wave since about
june in fact so what's he talking about
yeah it's really interesting isn't it i
mean there are rising cases in some
european particularly eastern european
countries rising quite starkly but one
of the charts they showed today showed
that actually british cases his numbers
are much higher than our closest
neighbors some of our closest neighbors
you know france spain
germany and um and so you know we've
been somewhere ahead of them on case
numbers and are fairly equal to them in
terms of vaccinations as well at the
moment so we're not in a great position
and it was struck me as rather odd that
the prime minister was suggesting that
these cases are all going to arrive from
the from europe and of course some
arrivals will some people will bring
covert with them but all the scientists
suggest that the single uh biggest
factor when it comes to determining case
numbers domestically is domestic
measures so the fact that we don't have
any uh currently in england obviously
doing scotland and wales but um you know
with face masks uh compulsory or
anything like that um
is probably the single biggest factor
why our case numbers are high uh but you
know as you've already said vaccines
seem to be the way out of this if you
want a normal christmas he's suggested
then you know people need to get their
jabs and the prospect of having another
christmas light last one hopefully will
encourage a few more people to go and
get that booster yeah we're running out
of time let's just see the story we were
going to talk about which was the metro
a labor plan to ban mps working as
consultants and in 10 seconds pippa just
remind us what's going to happen then on
wednesday
it says kiyostama has said that he's
going to table a motion in the commons
on wednesday to give mps the chance to
um to back a ban on mps working as
consultants or company directors given
all the ferrari over second jobs this is
quite a specific game he's basically
saying to mps including across the house
on the tory side time to put your money
when your mouth says you're not happy
about all of this time to act
both of you thank you very much i've got
time to hear your thoughts i'll have to
do it later on thank you very much
we'll see them shortly here's the
weather